so do you think most girls are objective
or do you think they think they're
hotter than they are personally i think
it depends on the person because growing
up i'm obviously not skinny hi everyone
i'm not skinny so growing up i was never
the beauty standard for anyone so like
all my friends were getting chatted up
by people blah blah blah blah i never
really thought of myself as
an attractive person like i would never
call myself anything more than a fall
but
now like i don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like i've
grown into myself and i'm comfortable
with who i am now that like even if you
guys call me delusion or whatever i
think i'm definitely an a per
so like
whether you guys think i am or not but
like what is it that took you from a
four to an eight if nothing's changed
what is it that takes loving myself and
and looking in the mirror and not being
disgusted at what i see i understand
that yeah so
but that doesn't you're not necessarily
being objective about how other people
view you